in the cage
[Music]
don't do stuff you're not supposed to do
[Music]
like
heckling
or talking at your table
all those things no you do not
thank you
it's good to be here this
critically successful show but
commercially
floundering
uh my name is hans kim this is a dating
show
unfortunately no one showed up to date
uh you know instagram won't let us buy
ads because it's a dating show and you
can't buy ads for dating shows because
then people will just buy their faces
and just solicit women so you're not
allowed to buy ads for dating shows
uh so we're just gonna do a little
podcast my guest host is sam lopez
[Applause]
hey
it's california's own san diego native
are you from san diego no i'm from
maryland god damn it
close maryland
same country same country exactly
same
uh latitude
ish a little bit lower a little bit
lower a little bit higher
uh different
not the same
so uh how have you been what's what's
the deal with you tonight
i'm chilling
wow
give it up for sam
yeah she's chilling i uh i was expecting
to
critique
i know some interesting dates over here
unfortunately
no one came out
i'm gonna get a little tipsy
drunk
we didn't make the creek any money so
we're gonna drink away our pain and
waste some more of their money yes
comics
the comics
like i said like good comics like good
comics do yep that's never let a comedy
club get away with making a profit never
we got to make sure that they're humble
cheers
cheers
thank you creek thank you creek
so i had a pretty good weekend i went a
little private jet a pj with uh great
joe rogan oh
how very interesting right
i thought so it's way cooler than my
weekend well
i mean i'm sure that you did some things
that would be considered cool that i
wasn't able to you know tell me about
the private jet what happened on the
private jet i really can't say too much
because you know opsec operational
security what were you wearing what did
you wear onto the project where you can
say that right
yeah these jeans were they these they
were like these
same color same color yeah or different
style colored
they're pretty much boot cut
you know
skinny fit
was everyone wearing jeans huh was
everyone on the private jet also wearing
jeans i really wasn't paying attention
ah damn can you tell us anything
uh there was a lot of charcuterie on
board there's always charcuterie around
joe rogan
i don't know if you've ever met him
he loves dried preserved
pesticide-filled meats love it love it
you know good salami some
dried apricots
dried apricot is the [ __ ] on a
charcuterie board it's the only edible
thing that's my favorite thing
yeah yeah you just chomp on those i eat
those uh joe rogan actually doesn't seem
to eat those i never said no he doesn't
it's just what they just put it out for
him it's just what people think rich
people eat
i think they think because he's so
muscular
they're like certainly he needs more fat
to support all this muscle right
it's too much there's too much lean
muscle nobody gets buff on dried meats
i think you could
what about um uh the boxer
you know he runs to the top rocky oh
yeah angela
well he did he eat a lot of beef jerky
or charcoal is there a lot of charcoal
they eat salami
you can't have a diet just on salami
you should ask jodie
i know it she says it on the podcast
which is salami
okay so you go on the pj where do you
guys fly on the pj to can we fly to
dallas yes okay we did a very public
show
uh in dallas texas the majestic theater
1700 a little small theater for joe but
a giant opportunity for yours truly
why is it so majestic
uh it was built in the 20s it smelled
pretty bad
smelled old our green room smelled like
[ __ ]
like literal [ __ ] yeah like sewage like
old sewage
that's the kind of
stuff that they think we like
huh the charcuterie the sewage
it was just you and joe it was a
beautiful theater we might have to cut
that part out
tony yeah i mean i'm sorry it smelled i
don't know is this live
yeah oh my god really
no it's not yeah
you're kidding me it's live
this is not live i forgot to mention
that we're live here at the creek in the
cave
for another episode of
revealing too much and talking [ __ ]
about opportunities that i got
i didn't feel like i mean we're mostly
talking [ __ ] about charcuterie yeah
well yeah i mean charcuterie was great
the majestic theater was great a
beautiful venue a little smelly but
it was a beautiful venue did the show
there amazing fun time
the crowd was very on board and then uh
we went to the ufc yesterday just
watched a little ufc
do you want to get a guest
should we get a guest on and we can
interview them yeah because i'm just
interviewing you hey you want to be a
guest
yeah get up here come on
your opportunity has arrived give it up
for this veteran
what's your name sir
this guy's definitely been overseas with
a ar-15
jimmy walker
give it up for him guys it's way too
intense
to be a civilian
what's up dude hey um how's it going
great how are you doing good doing good
what branch did you serve with
and neither
oh
you should have you i was in jrotc when
i was oh that's what i was getting yeah
it looks like you were targeted by army
recruiters
potentially yeah they have great posture
phenomenal
i try do you listen to papa roach
pop roach um don't talk to my father
like that no i'm not gonna contract
eminem eminem no i'm not like this
not i'm like an indie guy like tame
impala kinda
[Music]
[Laughter]
chasing cars by snow patrol
that's the only song i know that's so
old
give it up for 2010 babies 20 uh no
i guess my age
no
31. 31 clevis and 30. nice yeah yeah i
look like a baby but
um yeah you're an old man any words of
wisdom for our young listeners uh find
what you love and do it that's all that
matters what do you love
um
i love my job that i do now
um i breed clown fish for a living
clown here
is that where you [ __ ] clown fish um
yeah i do the barbie thing i make them
kiss but no it's um i work at a fishery
where we uh breed lots of clown fish and
who do you sell these to
petco and other
hey
yeah what would we do without you yeah i
know i buy saltwater fish so i can still
have a job
and uh yeah you're great you're out
there you're breeding clown fish selling
it to petco yeah there's actually
designer clown fish is if you didn't
know there's like is that what you do
yeah they're like um but you sell it to
petco all black ones all you sell to
petco though yeah yeah well i know the
designer part
designer you get into this field
luck craigslist
be white
yeah basically that helps
so when you're just doing designer
clownfish are you just hooking up
clownfish with some fish they normally
wouldn't be interested in yeah like um
you see a fine couple and you want them
to make more fine babies so you pick
those ones and then you hope potentially
you're judging babies for sexiness
yeah yeah
appeal because you can't sell ugly
babies you gotta sell the nice pretty
ones what makes them sexy
um
the more lines they got i guess i don't
know like uh some like blend together
it's a whole line yeah yeah baby look at
this sexy lines just clownfish
what do you think about finding nemo um
it's cool i haven't seen a fish that
hasn't messed up finn yet i'm still
looking for him i haven't found nemo yet
but that's because they're in the belly
of a shark
yeah
they don't get farther
you know
yeah but oh fun fact um clownfish are
actually hermaphedites
so they start off as a male and then
they become female later in life so nemo
can potentially be a nina like later on
in life nice that's what a lot of kids
in our generation are doing yeah it's
it's taken over
but i guess there's a bunch of clowns so
finding nemo's fault
for
nope
what do you think about uh
the general state of the economy right
now yeah that's actually a really good
question i want to know that too
uh the general state of the economy is
uh fluctuated on the gas price and
we have a gas price based economy yeah
it's like really how can i afford to
drive uber if i'm
paying ten dollars for gas
do you drive uber no i don't
all right he [ __ ] clown fish yeah
how many people do you think are driving
uber right now like the percentage of
americans are uber drivers
what do you think that is is there is in
our generation no currently like today
like what is the percentage of americans
two percent
that's i'll say more no
40
of us are just driving each other around
yes
i do think so 40 i think 40
in our generation maybe but if you
include children
uber and lyft
combined we can find this out
sam we need a guy behind the
we need a white man to do math for the
asian
but are you counting just uber alone or
are you doing like rideshare lyft just
uber and lyft uber lyft no taxis because
we'll be like i think as much as taxi
drivers there are is the equal amount of
what's the most racist thing you said to
a taxi driver um
i don't ride in taxis i think it's more
the things he did not the things he said
yeah i always give up it's always the
things you do
i got picked up i just landed today hey
welcome where are you coming in from um
i'm originally based in florida but i
came from seattle
so i'm like flying all over the country
i had to play the most
inefficient route are you also from
seattle sir
florida
what part
oh miami i'm like central i'm up in the
treasure coast
yeah treasure coast yeah that's where
all the pirates or tampa nable's at the
bottom it's like tampa across how do you
guys feel about winterhaven
kinda orlando
south of orlando it's like if you are at
tampa and you go straight across it's
like right there but above west palm
uh below orlando it's
nobody knows that much about florida i
just i just tell people miami and then
they get it west palm beach is north of
miami yeah but he said [ __ ] west palm
beach why do you hate west palm beach
what happened there
yeah it's kind of ghetto it's like
that's where trump lives he's in
mar-a-lago that's like on the coast of
west palm but then like if you go in the
back of west palms it's like the styx if
you go west oh what are you doing here
um just visiting um you're a tourist
yeah i'm tourist no i went to go see my
sister and i had uh in seattle so i
figured i'd had a layover in texas
anyway so i might as well pick a spot to
lay over at and actually enjoy the
layover so
i gotta fly back to
[Music]
uh
florida yeah
in a couple days so yeah i remember
where you're from
florida florida boy
what made you pick austin um i'm a fan
of the show
other people thank you you're the only
fan of the show i like all of them
i like all the posts yeah and just oh
[ __ ] yes i wish i was nicer to you
you know i feel kind of bad we just sort
of bombarded him yeah you're so mean i'm
not gonna like anymore your post anymore
i'm so sorry oh well i'll just have joe
rogan get me can we set the two of you
up on a date then can we [ __ ] oh yeah
pretend can we dress up like clown fish
and
mate we could break someone else up to
take your spot here and then you two go
on a date no
stop trying to make gayness happen
i don't have to make it happen man
it's already happening it's in the air
it is it's in the air it's everywhere i
wish it's in me
you got gay in you what kind of jet did
you fly on with joe rogan oh yeah what
kind of do you know uh i used to fuel
private jets too that was like my other
job before i started
with pipes
just put liquids and things
yeah
oh
i [ __ ] with water i guess it's
the most part but
um no yeah it's a hydrosexual
yeah
well
i think that you're
perfect for the military
you should definitely serve our country
because you look like you could really
commit some war crimes
yeah it seems like you're pretty
successful as a
clownfish sex trafficker
basically yeah have you ever carried a
clown fish over state lines
i played the fifth
nice well what do you think what do you
like about kill tony are you going
tomorrow yeah yeah i got tickets um
uh what do i like about it it's
i like bad comedians
like i like when they suck and he's a
fan of me yeah that's not reassuring i
like when i like when tony trashes them
and
yeah it's just a cool show and
working at a private airport i actually
seen
kill tony and them came in one time you
know his name's not actually kill tony
tony hinchcliffe yeah but he wasn't
there it was red band and joey diaz were
like chilling in the fbo and i was like
watching them do their things
so not kill tony at all
but then yeah and joey diaz who's never
been on kill tony no not yet are you a
big fan of the death squad empire
um
i'm not familiar with it no but
just all the people within the bubble i
guess is that the empire yeah i guess um
yeah protect our parks and all that like
you let your clown fish listen to joe
rogan podcast i listen to him while i
mess with the clown fish but
sometimes we have a loud speaker and
we'd be bumping like techno and all the
fish are just like in their tanks like
dumping but
now they they don't get any musical
clown fish feel pain
i don't know they're kind of smart but
they're kind of dumb at the same time
but um
yeah um
i guess
they kind of feel pain we we medicate
them like if they have something wrong
with them we'll like give them some like
neosporin or something to a sporadic
yeah how do neosporing them um
basically you just turn off their water
and then put a bunch of chemicals in the
water so it stays in the water and then
you leave it in the hands certain amount
of time and then flush it out do they
know what's happening in panic
no some are hard to catch some are
easier than others they have
personalities like some are like
aggressive and like bite me all the time
and others are like more than i can say
about you is plain old white piece of
bread
yeah just kidding
i need some cinnamon on me to spice it
up
it's got racial so fast
i can't help it this guy's so white yeah
look at this guy so
white rice
[Music]
but
i don't know i could do something with
the short hair but i can't think of
right now that would be that that'd be
the crack
are you going to sign up for kill tony
yeah you're going to sign up yeah i
would i have a minute but
you want to i've only done like two open
mics so
there's an open up mic later
well consider it three
oh this counts yeah okay
well
i'm bombing this one damn it
what do you like about your jokes
um it's a roller coaster of emotions
like it's
like a lot of twists and turns and like
like a jordan peel movie
yeah a little bit i haven't seen nope
yet but i would assume it's like that
but um yeah don't you think it's better
to stick with the simple jokes
um
yeah
it's good to trim fat
um
let's
yeah kiss keep it simple stupid you want
it to be simple enough for people to
understand but you don't want to be
too simple to be boring
yeah
kiss kiss keep it simple stupid
yeah he's not wrong you don't want to
get fomo
or
what are you talking about what are your
premises on
um my name's jimmy walker and he was a
famous black comedian from the 70s
so i'd play with that idea
because i'm like not so famous comedian
jimmy walker if i'm doing comedy because
there was already one to jimmy walker
before
so
i just play with that idea and
just a little bit i have two two jokes i
do about it but one i think is better
than other
like look at me i'm embodying the spirit
of jimmy walker
and then you're like white
so that's the joke
the body and spirit yeah there's also a
like a golfer jimmy walker
well jimmy
is there anything that you'd like to say
to
me or sam or
that guy
oh what happened to the other floor
floridian he left he's got a short
attention span he doesn't have a lot of
time in this world yeah audience i don't
know um i love the show i've been a long
time fan i like all your posts and yeah
thanks man that's goddamn he likes all
of them
very supportive the shitty ones
yeah yeah every single one i watch all
the stories and i record them
and oh god what do you record them for
what do you think i'm a clown for laters
for the fish you play them for the fish
but why do you need the recordings are
you saving them for something special
yeah so when their babies hatch they
know what consummated them
prior
no wonder i have such a connection with
marine life yeah that's you i've always
wondered why i could speak to them like
that you're sexually whispering to them
[Laughter]
what is the sexiest clown fish that you
have ooh we have a long fin clownfish
there i mean the black clown fish
they don't play basketball but is there
a ghetto
do you put them in the timeout table oh
yeah we have like a little jail if
they're being too feisty
put them in little boxes but wow
what did they do
they pick on each other were they not
clowning sometimes like how they're
hermaphrodites sometimes the
the male will turn female and wants to
lay eggs now and then picks on the other
female so it's like oh you gotta
separate them now because once when they
switch they switch and typical women am
i right wow
complicated like you think dating is
hard for humans
yeah
you just like think you're hanging out
with your friend and all of a sudden
like she wants to put your eggs i'm a
woman now
stop laying eggs
i hate it when my friends
turn female
is it happen
uh
no
not really
um but give it up for jimmy walker
[Applause]
thank you thank you
there's currently zero women besides sam
lopez in the building that's not true i
think carrie's back there
carrie
a producer
employee
uh
conrad
you want to be a guest on our podcast
hell yeah okay conrad
a local comedian
and
longmont potion castle
fan
he loves a good prank prank show
give it up for a conrad
the guy
[Applause]
wearing the right hat for this weather
is this uh yeah i know i was doing
something earlier this is um this is
probably the best protective gear that i
have though it's it's pretty good yeah
like when you see the construction
workers they all try to have something
like that yeah they do they are kitted
out they have a lot of gear
yeah the real ones with the are the ones
without it though the dude's just going
no no
feel the sun yeah
long sleeves too like i just want to
bake i just want to cook it doesn't look
like you can cook that much because
you're white as [ __ ] thank you yep
that's right everybody who hate white
people man
that's come up twice now we haven't done
that much great
you know we've kind of it's mozart
besides mode
besides mozart and eminem white people
don't really have much to be proud of
yeah white pride more like white shame
it's weird telling jokes to know people
this is this is live though right
they'll laugh they're live
is this really being live streamed yeah
whoa what's up kill tony heads how you
doing find me
are you ever gonna sign up for kill tony
i have just never got picked are you
ever gonna get picked for kill tony not
up doesn't feel like it's up to me i
think you're not doing the right stuff
seems like it's up to you my friend what
are you wearing what am i wearing yeah
when you go when you sign up what do you
wear swear normal clothes man are you
wearing racially insensitive fortune
cookie shirts that are appropriate asian
culture how is this appropriate asian
culture that's the asian people wear
t-shirts now is that a thing that only
asian people do wear shirts our
lettering is our culture this is chinese
bro you thought you were japanese
well you know who's to say what culture
is or is it definitely not a white man
i'm pretty sure white people probably
own this i don't know my girlfriend got
me this shirt white people own
everything
do they yeah yeah they do yes they do
and it's bad
and it's not good
thank you an apologetic white man no
problem i'm here for you you know i
i am your vessel you look like you can
never join the military
yeah no i would get [ __ ] destroy or
i look so [ __ ] up this is how i
rationalize it i look so bad that they
will put me in the like captain america
like super soldier program nice yeah
because you know captain america he got
4f'd you know what i mean they're like
this guy's the biggest [ __ ] we've ever
[ __ ] seen let's pump him full of
powers
and then he's [ __ ] captain america
imagine if they did that to someone that
was actually buffed it would he be even
more buff he would break the machine
yeah
yeah you just shatter that thing with
all the needles that goes in them
i don't remember how they did that you
seem like you'd be in vietnam writing
poetry and just being like war is dumb
war is hell
all those bob dylan songs are right
that's me yeah
i would have all the gear i would be the
guy with like the [ __ ] phone you know
what i mean yeah that's i would be that
dude
yeah what was the guy in uh
i did appreciate every time i saw a war
movie and they had glasses and there was
like a soldier with glasses yeah like i
felt represented i was like this is cool
this guy's out in the jungle killing
terrorists and he's
you know he doesn't need to have 20 20
vision to be a hero
no he's a weak man is that right
internet do you guys like this
that's the thing about the vietnamese is
that none of them had glasses
they didn't have glasses because their
president uh
what was that thing what country was
that vietnam vietnam the president had
glasses and it was like embarrassing
to wear glasses he didn't let anyone
wear glasses
this is me barely remembering history i
think cambodia or something yes it was
cambodia i'm pretty sure i don't
remember this at all yeah no it's not
just this i'm not making this up i don't
make things up sam connor i do i've
never made any i don't even think your
name is real you don't think my name is
real it does sound fake it is a fake
sounding name
i get it what's your last name
fagin it's fagin like from oliver yeah
the bad guy in uh greatest character in
all of musical history yeah well my
first name is also from a musical yeah
my mom named me after conrad birdie
from bye bye birdie
damn you come from the family of [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah as if my last name wasn't
gay enough it's like let's [ __ ] tack
something else on here name him conrad
so you decided to go with the more
grunge route they're more musical
theater you're more stand-up comedy more
sure yeah i just deal with things man
from a long line of performers you know
my mom did community theater
and so now i'm here basically this is
basically community theater and
community theater did your mom because
she's a [ __ ] dude what the hell i came
up here to just joke around and what the
[ __ ] was that fun i just came up here to
have a laugh what's your favorite way to
joke around with social humans
favorite way to jerk around with social
human joke around uh
i like to um
if people are doing like roasts or
whatever being mean i like to be mean
for fun and uh if people are being mean
to me i like to uh pretend that i didn't
hear the roast that they said but i want
them to repeat it really bad yeah and if
you can think of something to say no no
it just completely disarms the roast it
just doesn't make it funny anymore wait
what was that i didn't catch that but
like you gotta seem excited like you
want to hear it and they'll be like oh i
said you looked like uh like a uh like a
[ __ ] and it's just like whenever you
have to repeat a joke
it just doesn't it just takes away all
the [ __ ] they say nothing you little
[ __ ] yeah
i didn't say [ __ ] i've never talked
before once
that's fun that's good to know yeah
saying you're obsessed with me if
someone's roasting you if you just say
that you're obsessed with me that's
really funny
you'd be so good at being a girl i yeah
you know i was raised by women yeah you
have the same bone structure as a woman
same bone structure
same vagina you know we've got the same
everything you're a very pretty pretty
person thanks you're really downplaying
it i feel like if we took your glasses
off you'd be like that girl like
yeah it is i am handsome
we should your whole look is i'm not
trying yeah it is i think that's oh my
god oh [ __ ]
wait do we have a hat or something to
fix his hair do you have a hat
today i woke up today and i was
confident that i would not be in front
of a camera and that's why i'm dressed
like this on the bear on the bear yeah
get that hat
you look like you're naked even though
you're wearing clothes
yeah someone's i was changing clothes
one time in the green room and someone
said my skin looked new
[Applause]
this guy is a cowboy with an old shirt
the hell are you doing the hell are you
doing in my fortune cookie factory
this fortune cookie plantation has been
in my family for hundreds of generations
and i'm not letting any [ __ ] queers
take it from away from me i'm not
letting these asians take away my
fortune cookies i'm not letting these
asians take my culture all right
this is my family culture of fortune
cooking you've been stealing from the
asians from 1800s we've been
our culture has been stealing culture
and we're not about to let that change
this fortune cookery will be in my
family
for eons
no one can steal culture from someone
who steals culture that's right that's
all white persons culture is is just
meddling in other people's cultures and
like just saying just pretending you
invented it yeah you know elvis yeah i
was cooking with my girlfriend one time
and she's mexican and so we were making
like a mexican hey he has a girlfriend
what a humble brag
no i was uh we were cooking and i like
flipped the tortilla too early and she
like flips it back
and i was like that's kind of weird i
don't get cues i don't get social cues
at all so i just flip the tortilla again
and then she like does it and she's
getting mad she's like this is my
culture stop this this is like this is
kind of my culture and you're [ __ ]
with it and i was like well that's kind
of my culture
is to just like meddle in other people's
culture and just like pretend it's the
undercooked [ __ ] yeah to undercook [ __ ]
i caught it was a wrap we didn't have
tacos that night we had raps
and they were seven dollars each this
tortilla is the same skin tone as i am
it's specifically done it's perfect
that's just the way i want it
i like my tortillas pure do you put
mayonnaise on your tortillas no i don't
like mayonnaise
you don't like mayonnaise what is your
favorite thing that is white favorite
thing that is white
oh um
marshmallows
marshmallows are good or like things
white people like things white people
like marshmallows are good whipped cream
is good um
cinnamon cinnamon roll frosting is good
oh my god
shampoo you're gonna get cancer you're
one of those skinny guys that eats
unhealthy but doesn't get fat you just
get cancer
no i don't think i'm gonna get cancer at
all i've come from like a big my mom
hates it a lot but my whole dad's side
of the family hasn't gotten coveted once
and uh
famously the same thing as cancer yeah
exactly the same we just don't get sick
we don't die no one in my family's
gotten cancer it's a different kind of
thing it's cancer is almost like you're
too healthy
yeah
that's a good compliment that's what i
tell people with cancer i'm like you
know actually people who are too healthy
get cancer like your cells are like i'm
better than the rest of all these others
yeah it's your cells are doing like what
i'm doing with my clothing you know what
i mean they just decide to just decide
to look like [ __ ] and be shitty yeah
just like we've we've lived too long
we've had it too good for too long it's
like no i mean i got like cancer is like
a british tv show they're just like
we're done oh yeah they know how to do
that yeah it just comes out of nowhere
and it's around forever no one knows
about it
and then people find out about it and
they're like we got to get this out of
here we got to get rid of this i feel
like you have really good taste in tv
shows and music that no one's ever heard
of
not really i listen to i do pretty
normal stuff
i listen and watch t uh pretty normal
stuff it's normal i tried when i was
like a teenager that was my identity was
like being into things but
now i just kind of hang out and that was
two years ago yeah no i'm
thank you i'm gonna keep that rumor up
i'm 20 guys 21 years old
thank you nice sexy young boy
what do you get what are you guys
into
asian food i'm flipping it on you bro
what's the best asian thing at like a
chinese restaurant that i should order
but i've never ordered before the
express
okay you went from asian to specifically
chinese i'm gonna go to a chinese
restaurant and ask them to pick me up
panda express
and bring it to the table can i have the
panda yeah rare
well as you go to a asian restaurant a
menu has like 400 items but i always
just get like general sales chicken
one of the variations of chicken nuggets
that they serve
yeah like orange chicken sesame chicken
stuff like that but
i see like nuggets if there's like a
family of like chinese immigrants in the
restaurant they get [ __ ] i've never seen
before in my life
yeah i don't know you're not chinese but
i was just closer than most huh
i only get the free samples i don't buy
things at panda express yeah it's like a
costco yeah you just go there you're
like i want to try this oh this is a new
let me try oh i was no i was talking
about chick-fil-a
i was i've never seen a family i've
never seen a chinese person at panda
express i was talking about like chinese
restaurants
oh yeah i've never seen chinese people
at chinese restaurants either
really
what chinese restaurants are you going
to panda
all
express
one guy
well one out of
four
any women that's 25 of the audience
no if two people like a joke that's like
half the room that's awesome that's good
numbers all dudes
well what do you think about dating are
you like into it i hate it exposing
yourself to the female community no i
got a girlfriend i got one girlfriend
how did you find her four years ago just
i was visiting here who gave who coveted
first
i'm sitting here from where
from kansas city where i'm from
yeah and so you met her i met her though
right huh you you nabbed her while she
was visiting no i visited here
oh four years ago and then you found her
and you moved here i came here because
my buddy
glenn lived here and i was just coming
down to hang out and see i came into a
bunch of money because i got hit by a
truck and so i figured i had an
opportunity to move away from kansas
city
um thank you
we can get into it a little later on a
different show
but i was
just visiting checking it out and i was
at cheer up charlie's which is a bar on
uh red river it's a great bar and uh it
was me it was like friend of a friend of
a friend like i was hanging out with my
friends their mutual friend had friends
with him one of those friends
texted her after we left like we were
talking whatever bullshitting i didn't
think anything of it and then like
later that night
my girl now my girlfriend texts my
friend and said hey that guy was
that guy was a real catch that guy
seemed real snazzy yeah
no she didn't say snazzy i'm just trying
to be funny
no but what do you think she really said
like she said i was funny and cute in
the tags if you want if you want real
info if you want cold hard truth
i thought it would be funnier to say
snazzy's a funnier word than cute
doesn't mean he's not funny and cute is
everything it's less accurate yeah i was
funny and cute and then so that's
literally never happened before so i was
like i'm gonna hold on to this one as
hard as possible and uh
then yeah i mean i was like
we hung out she came to i did a show
here when i was visiting at a place that
doesn't exist anymore but it was called
frank and it was like a hot dog themed
bar
it was pretty tight um so she came after
you
she no she lived here
no she was like i need to find this guy
you were like whatever yes exactly yeah
she pursued me i liked that a lot and
how badly does she need that green card
um
that's very racist to say
is it yeah it is it hurt my feelings i
think yeah now the room's all quiet hans
are you happy
[Music]
racism no she just liked me she just
liked my vibe
and uh i'm sure that's rare that very
rare that's why i kept her that's why i
like you know held tight because this is
the one person who my vibe doesn't scare
off immediately i don't have to like
i can only become friends with somebody
if i'm like in a social setting that we
both have to be in over a long course of
time yeah you know what i mean like i'm
not a good first impression you're like
they call me the long con yeah made off
yes
like bernie madoff cool i mostly just
become friends with people who i have to
be around
uh but your exposure effect
what
is that like social science is that
david great exposure are you quoting
graber on me david graber yeah
is any more of an anthropologist that's
really into it that's social science
isn't it
yeah well you're you just you just like
wear people down usually and yeah hey
look i haven't gone away yeah i'm
reliable that's mostly it so i'm
consistent you know what you're gonna
get from me
every time every single like mcdonald's
boyish you know look like oh look this
is a giant child
maybe i did look like a giant child when
i met her i had no facial hair
whatsoever i had hair like down to here
she probably thought i was a woman
um
and uh now
he's dating a lesbian nice i am dead
yeah how can i be homophobic guys my
[ __ ] is gay ah you're gay yes
what do you say
you're gay what you're into women
say that to my face bro you're a woman
that's into women why don't you take
that [ __ ] and say that to my face
i don't
you should do weigh-ins with your guests
up here
should you like sterile i can already
tell how much you weigh how much do i
weigh 147 pounds damn that's really
close i know how much you're within
you're definitely within five pounds
over under
was it 150 it's 150. i weighed myself
recently
and went up for this featherweight
is that featherweight you know about
you're the fighting expert now i don't
know is it featherweight featherweight
isn't the lowest but it sounds like it's
i thought it was bantamweight
bantamweight yeah that's what i am right
that's like the twink class southern way
to say a band to my bandham way bantam
what do you how do you say my cousin's
name i'm sorry i don't get invited to
ufc events for free dude i don't know
how to pronounce bam tam bontam wait is
it bonton that's nice cool that sounds
dope
that's what i wrote in to get to america
hans is a gundam weight fighter
rice weight i really hate how there's no
one in here
i weigh the same as miso soup
sashimi wait all right so uh are you
athletically inclined or are you more uh
computer nerd
uh are you somewhere in the middle there
i used to skate board a lot and then i
got hit by a [ __ ] truck on the side
oh you deserved it yeah yeah yeah it was
i was vandalizing city property with my
it's like free willy
what yeah
who am i in free willy
the guy the guy that got caught
graffitiing the sea world right yeah
skateboarding is kind of a type of
graffiti
um yeah it's graffiti of the body
no i was skateboarding and uh do you
have any tattoos yeah i do have a tattoo
yeah you show us on youtube
yeah no for sure it's it's like a thigh
tat so that's still safe right yeah i
think how are you gonna get it i think i
can meet i'm wearing sweatpants today
i'm wearing athleisure so i think i can
pull them up
same thing your girlfriend is wearing
that's right yeah exactly she dresses so
much better than me dude she's so hot
where's the where do i show the tattoo
too right over there okay all right guys
uh i got this tattoo to make fun of my
my girlfriend has a bunch of awesome
tattoos she's really [ __ ] sexy like i
said and uh everyone [ __ ] conrad's
girlfriend don't do that do not do that
do not [ __ ] my girlfriend i will be so
mad if i find out any of these four
weird dudes [ __ ] my girlfriend
um
150 pounds so we were chilling at the
tattoo place because she was getting a
piece do you want to hold it for him and
then uh
yeah yeah yeah the consummate showman he
can't get away from the mic i love to
talk uh whoa
i see his dick my face oh my god this
guy's like pete davidson i've got a long
penis
is that the tasmanian devil yeah it's
the tasmanian devil riding a motorcycle
with a gun
uh and like a world war one
helmet
it was uh i got it because
my girlfriend always gets tattoos and
then complains about how much they hurt
and so i wanted to get one
to
prove that it doesn't hurt
yeah and also that tattoos are dumb so i
got a looney tunes motorcycle biker
tattoo you just think everything's a
joke don't you yeah this is pretty funny
isn't it it's hilarious all right so as
soon as it stops being funny i will
regret it um did it hurt yeah it hurt
really [ __ ] bad it sucked
getting a tattoo hurts really bad and
then i have this little i have a little
fly that you can see
right there
yeah yeah this guy's
like a real man
my body is a gallery han
yeah it's very small
grassroots gallery
a bantamweight gallery
that's right i'm like a mini museum i'm
like that mini museum that got destroyed
in
some obscure news thing you guys see the
news this guy's perpetually online
what's the craziest thing that you've
seen online recently recently
uh some guy
told me about nugget porn
is that chicken nuggets like in panda
express that's what exactly what i
thought my friend because we're both
pure souls but nugget porn
is
where one one party in the sexual duo
is a quadruple
legs quadruple quadruple amp it's got to
be quad amp and uh you gotta have the
quad it's got to be the quad you can't
be paraplegic
the thigh gap on that person no
monopolies oh yeah the thigh gap is like
it's like [ __ ] 190 degrees you know
what i mean it's just wide as hell uh
but it's a guy [ __ ] uh like a
quadruple amputee it's really gross it's
really messed up i tried to look it up
on pornhub and it was just like fat
women eating chicken nuggets and i was
like that's this isn't it and so i had
to go on a website called heavy r dot
com hey heavy r dot com yeah don't go
there if you go there you belong in jail
[ __ ] disgusting too long heavy r is
evil all roads all roads all roads lead
to heavy armor all roads lead to heavy
armor yeah there's so much porn along
the way why do you need to go that far
hey do you remember
what was happening do you remember x
hamster yeah why was it called that
why'd they call what is this bumping
mics
uh
why do they call it ex-hamster who knows
all right moving on well um nugget porn
is great nugget porn's cool it's a fun
time your tattoos i think that's gross
though i think i want to make a stance
and say nugget porn is bad
i do think amputees deserve love but i
don't think it should be [ __ ] filmed
i don't i think they should [ __ ] but
don't film that [ __ ] because they're so
helpless
yeah i think that's a part of it is like
if they stop liking it they have no
control over what happens why don't they
just flex their abs
yeah what's that going to do it's going
to make it more pleasurable for the for
the top
momentum going yeah i don't know what
that is yeah
well limbs are very important to humans
we're pretty much we need them mostly
limbs we [ __ ] need those things yeah
i feel like if i lose one of them i
can't even do [ __ ] you know
have you ever lost a limb let alone four
no i've never lost a limb i almost lost
a my foot when i was when i got hit by a
truck and i'm kind of mad that i didn't
because having a fake foot would be
awesome
damn you got hit pretty hard by this
truck i got [ __ ] up
i got my neck broken ribs broken pelvis
broken
foot completely destroyed the kind of
fracture on my foot it's called a liz
frank fracture and that's where all the
like the main the like bones in the the
top of the foot right here break and
that kind of only ever happens to
professional nfl athletes so wow
you make it look so easy i make it look
easy yeah maybe getting hit by a truck
on the sidewalk has never been easier
why was he on the sidewalk he was
running from the cops and hit some other
dude i was by an intersection i was on
the sidewalk by the way where cars
aren't supposed to be and people are
and the sidewalk yeah the sidewalk yeah
where people the people the safe haven
of humans on the road
uh they belong and the this guy hit a
guy and skidded out of control and hit a
uh
me
hit a conrad hit of me launched me about
12 feet into a bush completely out of
sight if i was with my roommate and uh
my roommate had to be like to the emts
be like yo we gotta find this other guy
because i was missing he's like there's
an easter egg in here somewhere yeah no
it's like i clipped out of the map like
i was just completely gone i'll let you
find him but yeah yeah i don't know
where it is history that's crazy you
know car culture is dangerous we
shouldn't have a car based
infrastructure because it's really yeah
it's weird how many people have cars and
how many people think they need uh to
have a car well you do if you live in
texas just because everything's so
spread apart but if you lived in a
public transportation density yeah uh
neighborhood like europe then it really
is better a better way to live but thank
you conrad for coming on the show
he's a human being yeah abolish fossil
fuels everyone
amen he's got some wack-a-doodle ideas
but we still love it
even though
his race is the reason why thank you
podcast fans i love you all bye all
right paul
cyphers
is our next guest
a human being
a man
who is very nice
and also a comedian
what's up i thought you had to be single
to be on the show
otherwise i would have
are you single where's the the army man
he's leaving
are there any single people because i'll
break up my girlfriend right now that's
what it means she's not here
justin
is single
so how's your girlfriend aka your mom
what what's that supposed to mean dude
you're like stuck to her you're like so
pussy-whipped
i love my girlfriend is there some
personal [ __ ] happening here
ever since he's been dating this girl
he's not hanging out with us as much
haven't you guys been together for like
a year i think it has more to do with
you having a career or me not having a
career is why we don't hang out very
often you know i mean well i can't [ __ ]
my career
so count your blessings
uh she's great she's doing great uh
bipolar as ever um
nice
she's more pulls the better she keeps
her weight she can [ __ ] you with it
weighs herself on a calendar every
single day so i can track she's at a
real high right now she's at like 140.
it's you know she's very bummed out
about it
but is that like the kinsey scale for
bipolar people yo
this is too much for me
um you look like one of the children
boys from stranger things
but the haircut you look like you'd be
one of the young boys on stranger things
right now
i feel like you're dressed like one of
the young boys on stranger things
all right
damn conrad was doing a lot better than
me up here i know i'm more of a writer
everybody can we get your girlfriend up
here yeah let's bring both of you up
here and you guys go on a date and we
talk about
where this is going like are you guys
gonna get married uh have kids she's
going out tonight and i was hanging out
here to make sure that we don't cross
paths when i go home oh well you guys
are you gonna get married and have kids
i hope so in her period uh no it's just
you know
interactions i try to limit them as much
i feel like she's gonna get tired of me
we spend too much time together it's a
good strategy yeah you want to be
sparingly showing yourself yes
can i make a suggestion sure
take out the trash okay
that means
move and break up with her because
you're trash literally just take your
trash out
we just have to put our trash in our
hallway and i can't even bring myself to
do that we agreed that we're going to
clean the apartment together this
morning and i just laid in bed and
played diablo while she cleaned the
apartment so yeah she's gonna get tired
of you i know are you sure you're not
bipolar
yeah i don't have health care so it's
quite possible
um
bipolar is for rich people who have
doctors yeah i just have poor drug
addiction from self-medicating whatever
it is do you have any wheat on you i
have delta eight you want some of that
so no does that work
on you um
i don't know it does something it makes
me feel
something
makes you feel like you wasted your
money yeah
yeah it makes me feel that way too
check out delta eight sold here at the
creek in the cave
hey conrad's got some weed
he's shaking it at us
probably
no
this is texas baby we have freedoms
you ever seen something like this in
your whole [ __ ] life
drug dealer rolling loud
this is what happens when white people
get weed can i be paul's girlfriend for
this yeah sure all right
let's work out some scenarios all right
because yeah paul has asked me for
relationship advice before
um
yeah what was the advice i asked you
the advice was uh
was it how to
pretend that she's a guy better oh was
that
yeah you're you're you're
secretly into gay people and you're
reluctantly [ __ ] a woman yes let's go
with that that's why he made her shave
her head you know you know she has a
shaved head that wasn't her choice at
all i think that was the bipolar but
she's got bipolar
is she rich
she has a really good job
and
i pay rent late a lot
if any aspiring artist in the crowd what
you want to do is you want to find a
person who will float you
yeah you're saying
a rich partner yeah you're such an
artist you're even creative about when
you pay rent don't date another comic
date a person who's rich
alissa was a comic and then i made her
quit so i didn't have to date it kind of
like that's why she doesn't do standard
and now we get another straight white
man yeah common plastic that's what we
needed
we didn't have enough don't have enough
it's tough all the diversity just one
more time things have never been harder
for straight white guys it's been really
hard for you guys i'm actually i'm
french canadian american so i'm not
white i can see it i'm a poc person and
i'm irish canada i can see it
yes you didn't have to say these yeah
you're like black irish yeah yeah we you
know they were oppressed too so think
about that folks
by y'all where's arjun team hey irish
nations built the railroads
irish asians i know the
irish
what is the railroad the french
canadians they killed the natives the
huguenots that was mostly there
yeah they just started at the top and
just moved their way down just well
until you do a 23andme i'm not going to
take anything i am my parents actually
they had to get a blood test before they
had children because they realized that
their families were both from the small
same small town in canada and it was
like we're like yeah we're related
enough we can make an incest baby
brother and sister i kind of have
forrest whitaker eye so there probably
is some type of they were trying to they
were trying to make sure there wasn't
too much genetic distance yeah
it's like the opposite of a blood test
where you want to make sure that your
siblings yeah i want to keep it pure
confirm you guys are like royals in
england in the 1400s
so
let's say that you're a woman and you're
paul cipher's excellent that would be
constant sad boy
uh am i a different woman or am i his
woman am i alyssa
sorry i won't say my name is alyssa
spatula
um okay he's alyssa
his name is sure i'm your girlfriend all
right are you alyssa
so put the mic on no one wants to hear
melissa melissa my name is melissa
melissa etheridge is here
i can play melissa etheridge
so do i start let's say that you come
home early and you didn't expect you're
here and she's being bipolar and you're
like oh uh
can you pull that off can you do bipolar
show me you're bipolar
i know you're [ __ ] texting other
girls
no you're talking about me you were just
talking about me melissa here right now
no she's not she's working
i think she's right there you were just
texting someone about me before you
walked in what were you texting what
were you texting i was telling someone i
want to make nugget porn with you i want
to have the denver nuggets have sex with
you what does that even mean
what does that even mean do you even
like me
who are i feel like i don't know who you
are anymore do you like me
yes baby tell me you love me i love you
you want me to do nugget porn like that
i'd like you more if you brought that
140 pound number down 10 or 15 but
well would it make you happy if i cut
off my arms and legs for you that
probably would bring you below the
weight that i would like yeah yeah
that's of course what you would want you
just want me for my [ __ ] body you pig
who are you texting and seeing
wait i have so many questions
first what is what is the the weight she
needs to be in order for your
relationship to work
um
uh
armless legless when you start dating a
girl this is advice
i'm pretty good at advice about
relationships date a really skinny girl
because when she gains a little bit
she looks even better you know what i
mean like you have a lot of buffer for
her to let go because then she's got
more but if you start dating girls
already teetering then it's like that's
not gonna work i'm the worst influence
on her she blames me for quitting comedy
she blames me for her eating habits and
she's kind of right because we're very
codependent and i'm not like a guy that
aspires to be a better person you know i
mean what do you think i should do
brother i always tell her it's like it's
not my fault that when i eat junk food
you have to eat junk food too how do you
do that you really are native american
yeah
meaning what i mean you're an alcoholic
yes reservation dweller
you're mistreating your squad right now
dude
i own a casino um you got a pocahontas
paul is a great guy paul just likes to
pretend that he's a piece of [ __ ]
because he hates himself
yeah that makes him better yeah his
girlfriend completely did everything on
her own volition i think yeah
you know what i mean where it's like she
blames me she's like okay we're gonna
have a no spend week and i'm like why is
my your financial decisions because she
orders like a million things off amazon
like why do i have to be involved with
that i don't want to do it it's marriage
role play dumb ass how much i spend
she's stress testing you for when you're
like legally bound you're not supposed
to spend but who's making the money what
do you do what do you do for a living i
deliver food on ubereats and grubhubs
she's part of the four percent
and do you share the rent or i pay a
segment of the rent not a 55th share but
he only comes with feminism you're ready
uh no i mean i've been trying to be but
i actually had to switch to a weekly
program paying for the rent because i'm
very bad at budgeting
my money
so it's easier if i just pay every week
god damn it yeah you're like a [ __ ]
underprivileged neighborhood you're like
a [ __ ] western union you're having
like a male boarding house paying weekly
to stay in a place is really bad yeah
yeah it's like a rental center you need
to grow up
all right well
that's hurtful
paul moving into a girl's apartment is
like a boost mobile opening up yeah we
moved in together just because not
headed in the right direction
they raised my right at my other place
so you're lowering the property value of
your girlfriend's [ __ ]
we're devaluing your girlfriend right
now well the denver nuggets moved into
my building and the property value went
straight down you know what i think
would increase your girl's value
cut those arms and legs off
nug it up
knock her up baby
up
knock her up
kill tony fans i love you oh
[ __ ] transitioning let's
not get it hell yeah let's do nugs
speaking of nugs speaking of nugs
remember this [ __ ]
these are the dumbest people ever you
guys conrad with schedule one narcotics
in texas that's right they call me
schedule one
what would i do if conrad didn't save
this interview up here
thank you i'm just here to have fun
buddy we're writing sketches together me
and conrad we're screenwriters
what are you writing i'm key he's peel
yeah
we're doing a we're doing we can't tell
you this guys will both be pure you
might be demonetized one of the sketches
is titled america's next top slave so
that's right
don't do that dude you're trying to
don't [ __ ] with him just get that out
there someone's gonna steal that yeah
that's a hundred we're gonna see that on
some golden idea great idea all right
[ __ ] i don't know any of you black
or are you just talking it's going to be
an irish irish black a boxer box boxes
rebellion yeah we're going to have a box
sex slave that shows up and is like this
is something different than i thought it
was going to be we're just describing
this to you guys because we know that it
could never get made i want somebody why
can't we just make it here right now it
would cost millions of dollars we need
to pay howard stern to be in the sketch
um
we need to get stern and we need to get
lights we need to get like the buttons
with the x's
um i think we can make that happen
yeah you're more chubby one he's the
skinny one that's very hurtful we're
like laurel and hardy oh yeah i see that
too so
should we do not burn any more sketches
dude more like hard ease because i'm
chubby laurel and hearties
uh paul what do you think about the
whole comedy scene here in austin yeah i
think there are a lot of talented people
here
where are they i don't know they don't
support each other's shows that's for
sure um
you know i don't know i uh is that a
woman that's a woman in the crowd if you
were a woman you were required to sit
everyone act normal there's a woman in
the crowd woman alert woman alert
we technically need a woman to go on a
date would you be willing to go on a
date live on stage on youtube tonight
[ __ ]
no there's someone else
i feel deceived
sam can sense a woman in here i sense a
woman's touch they're synced up there's
breasts in this building the
moon magic is strong in here right now
what is that what is it with women's
bodies a woman is talking conrad
what did you say woman
sorry sweetheart
sorry tuts
sorry for interrupting you tuts
did you say i think there's a [ __ ]
woman talking right now
hey quiet there's a [ __ ] talking
there's a [ __ ] talking respect the
broad
you want anyways you want to come up if
you're a woman please come up here and
go on a date not with me or paul so it's
safe it's good fresh we'll give you this
guy you can bring your friend
he's served in the armed forces yeah you
want to go on a date with your friend
you want to cut your arms and legs off
here she comes get the [ __ ] out of here
she comes
the most beautiful woman in the world
where is she there she is she comes the
stairs are right over there
please
make your way in a calm orderly fashion
we got a beautiful date for you with
this guy he's white
[Music]
come on up here single man
he's asking for permission from her
boyfriend to go on a date
[Music]
this is hello anywhere this is the
opposite of nugget porn it's very
beautiful and romantic
here we're going for jimmy walker and
what was your name
juanita
one minute starting now
one
i i guess we're on a date now
did i just steal you from your other
date or who's who's that
okay how long have you guys been dating
uh
three years three years
wow
so
um three years till today because now
you're with no
yeah that's lame yeah i don't go on
dates often so
it's um
so are you from austin or are you
mike right to your mouth please
from san marcos san marcos yes
okay i don't i've never been to mexico
so is that
yeah
oh i never been to texas apparently
so
um
[Laughter]
showing off my whiteness
here um
so do you like it here i guess yeah
um it's okay and time
jimmy walker and juanita
we're gonna interview you now thank you
jimmy for asking
juanita a woman who was born here if she
likes it here
she was born here
she [ __ ] loves it here
okay as long as you're still staying san
marcos famously a city in texas
uh you confused it with mexico
yes
um
that's okay he's from florida yeah i'm
florida guy you can't hold that against
him
yeah there's [ __ ] is all named okie
cheeky and yeah
and
a whole bunch of okeechobee and
all that we got weird names in florida
uh what's what's like a piece of florida
knowledge that you use to impress the
ladies oh yeah um how do you escape an
alligator
you know what you gotta run in zigzags
because they're good at straight lines
but they can't do corners
and if you're in the water you're kind
of screwed so okay yeah well what if
they already have you in their mouth um
you got to know jiu-jitsu and just roll
out of it or something just roll out of
it some florida knowledge yeah if if you
don't roll while they're death rolling
then they're gonna just rip the arm off
so you might as well roll with the
alligator if you can
[Laughter]
have you ever rolled with an alligator
before
i have not
no
what's the craziest animal you've seen
in san marcos mexico
the craziest i don't know a snake
a snake
a rattler oh
you saw a rattlesnake classic san marcos
yes
hell yeah
what'd you do shoot it with your colt
i did it it was
it was shot
it was shot by someone else
your brother yes slash boyfriend
sure
no i'm sorry i didn't mean to accuse you
of being related to your girlfriend
that's my job and the white boys
i'm appropriating your culture
so uh what how did you meet your
boyfriend
um from work
oh
what do you guys do
well i
i work at a joey well we worked at a
jewelry together what's the church
center
a juvenile detention center
you work there i worked there
all that teenage rebellion got you guys
all heated
we were different shifts so
just invited him out one day and
he
he did not take a test just to go out
with me and so yeah three years later
he's like this guy has no sense of
responsibility
i can ruin his life perfect i wouldn't
know he's about to graduate so
from juventus
state
penitentiary
that's what they call i graduate
i graduated
to the halfway house
what was the craziest thing that's
happened on like one of your shifts like
she [ __ ] someone
that was on another ship yeah
nice yeah pretty much you saw him from
across the shift
you're like i like the way this guy
clocks out that guy's not underage
he is
i'm older than him so oh nice how much
i'm 29 he's 26. yo that's criminal
cradle robert
how old were you when you met him um
three years ago
wow you're afraid that you're gonna give
away some bad information
so he was 23 looking after 18 year olds
in juvie or 17 year olds that's like the
blind leading the blind yeah did you
ever have juvenile like delinquents come
on to you
yes yeah yeah they're delinquents
that's what they are
did they ask you where you were from
no they don't know
they got more they got more game than me
apparently
they don't what did they say what was
their move
the what what would they say the kids
yeah
hey i saw you across the yard
do you want me to shank someone for you
[Laughter]
sam is hispanic so
i don't really have any much to show for
that
do you speak spanish no okay can you
pretend
hola
yes
[Laughter]
so what's the craziest thing you've seen
on a shift at juvie
um
i don't know just
a riot
a riot of children was justin bieber
there
no
just the cops going in that was about it
like it wasn't on my shift it was just
all these little footages is it all boys
it's voicing
with when the right was going on yes so
it's not about boys but it's mixed
yo
delinquent girls are way scarier than
the boys yeah they are girls
horrifying
catch me outside girl yeah this stuff is
scary
do they ever throw period blood at each
other oh yeah have you ever seen that
they've thrown poop
yo that's better
like the period like they would just
like stick it on the wall like like
civilized
human beings
i've seen that do they make art with
their period
they're expressing themselves
this guy actually [ __ ] clownfish yeah
we found that out earlier now he breeds
them yeah
yeah there's no no riots at my job no
maybe you could bring this guy to your
juvie and be like hey if you play your
cards right you could be
they're hiring breeding clowns
[Laughter]
hey would you ever uh be a little juvie
counselor would you ever counsel the
youth gotta counsel the youth i don't
know i can't even counsel myself you
can't make them [ __ ] like you do your
clown fish
like
like this is a good juvie
get the super juvie
um anyways i'm definitely not allowed to
apply for a job there now
um but yeah what do you what do you like
to do within juvie to pass the time
just turn the lights off see how they
react
they have their own program so
they're pretty much their day is set for
at least with me on my shift but what do
you do what's your capacity
our capacity what's what is what is your
job title what is um
sergeant
sergeant holy [ __ ] just there she's the
military one not me yeah no do you feel
the urge to salute her
she's a higher rank so yes
so what do you do as a sergeant
so i just basically i used to raise the
kids and that's it
i supervise the kids they have like a
room like this and i mean they sleep
there they
like that's that that's their house yeah
okay
you just watch them sleep depressing
it's depressing
do you like it a little high before you
go to work
it's not going live on youtube by the
way i cannot
yeah you might have too much fun then
uh
jimmy walker
have you ever been
almost sent to juvie or jail no i was a
good kid i didn't like start smoking
weed until like after high school
like i was that kind of guy
um what a stand-up citizen yeah such a
good guy i know
you waited
yeah you waited until marriage
are you a virgin till diploma no
no i
wish you've had sex oh you wish you
didn't have sex yeah you're 30 years
what happened no no i just i feel like i
could get more uh puddy [ __ ] if i had
was still a virgin i could use that as a
card to get more so you wish you didn't
have sex
why don't you just say that you're a
virgin
you look like one yeah no one's gonna
like yeah i'll put that in my tinder
profile i guess if
you really want to use it yeah
yeah all you need is a desire as long as
you want to be a virgin
that's how it works in christianity you
just have to give your virginity back to
jesus christ and he'll make you whole
again jesus can take my virginity
exactly you can have it it'll suck the
semen right out of your [ __ ]
um after you put it there but no no i've
been laid before
oh no
so is your boyfriend still in juvie
no he's out
yes he's at school
what does he do now
he is
you don't know
is he a superhero
yes he works for a hero yeah
nra is he [ __ ] clownfish
he's the law
he's what he's the law the law
he's the law oh
he's robert
he's an officer of the law thank you for
your service sir for your service sir
please don't take it in my car
so he works right over there right
across seventh street
um new braunfels
nice that's where the crime is you gotta
go where the crime is you gotta go where
it is man
right next to san marcos yes
how many kids do you have like at a time
there like how many are you watching
over or i could have up to twelve
twelve
twelve
so can you pretend like this guy's a
juvie that's acting up and give him your
best yeah show us what you do how would
you put him in his place [ __ ] you i
ain't doing [ __ ] this is a life he has a
shiv
[Laughter]
you have your brother shooting
yeah
you just called the other guys we got a
1091 or something
at 10 10. oh that was close
10 10.
a couple people go running and they just
restrain them that's about it
adventures of 10-10.
uh juanita i can ask you a question yeah
so when you met your your significant
other over here
he was also a juvenile he worked in with
you yeah and then he and then he became
a
an officer i won't say what he does
specifically but he got the badge he's
the law he's the law
did that
turn you on
a little bit
yes yeah dude wow
career advantage the gun or is it the
career advancement yeah
it's the whole uniform
of course it is that's right you can
just buy that [ __ ] on amazon you could
yeah no it's not it's not the same it's
not the same
it's all about intention right yeah
well you know we could
continue
with me it's the opposite like my mom
was a cop so uniforms like turned me off
like
because yeah i would see my mom and her
police get up going to work and i'm like
oh yeah it's my mom and so like ladies
and uniforms is like a total turn off
wait you don't want to [ __ ] your mom no
i don't that's all why dude are you all
right what's wrong it's so weird
you don't want to [ __ ] your mom
white people you know
you gotta you gotta
deal with that man yeah that's my curse
about me that doesn't wanna i can't join
a woman in uniform just because it's
like my mom is just
what was your mom like
no she's nice my parents were divorced
so i didn't see her much but i know
that's why yeah but no that's
interesting did your mom beat your dad
up
no
no
no my dad was just a stoner and then my
mom was like [ __ ] you arrested him
yeah something like that
that's interesting so whenever you see a
person in a cop's uniform you're like
give me a ride to softball practice yeah
yeah basically
buy me a sample make me a sandwich yeah
yeah and how does that usually go do you
respect the uniform or are you pretty
rude
um no it's cool she would like give
officer so she did that for a little bit
but then she worked at the mall and it
was just easy work why didn't you bring
that up when we were talking about juvie
earlier that's not what i said something
in common you couldn't think of a jail
connection oh yeah
yeah my mom she's such a good juvenile
correctional officer
he knows the system yeah
now it was cool i got my like um
was it uh hours for school like he had
to do community service we went to like
uh a theme park in florida and i got
like chaperone hours for being part of
the explorer program because my mom was
a cop and it like trickled down and yeah
typical white man exactly so your mom
was paula blart mall cop oh
i don't think she had the segway though
she didn't get one of those paula
blurred walker
[Laughter]
that's cool what do you think about this
man with the history of uh criminal uh
protection
people in his and his family that's
similar to what you do
it is but now he's [ __ ] clownfish so
yeah
yeah
i wouldn't want to be a cop though i
didn't want to follow my mother's
footsteps and i feel like it's just i
hate being that guy telling people they
can't do [ __ ]
that's like yeah it's like you can't
know bad i'm like i don't give a [ __ ] do
what you want so it's like i wouldn't
want to be a that guy yeah murderers
just murder oh just have i don't want to
tell you not to murder yeah that's so
i'm busy watching clownfish [ __ ] i ain't
got time for this you've obviously never
been to san marcos
yeah that's right is that the ghetto
part or is it like it's in mexico too
it's another college town oh it's called
yeah they got a good river there
they do a river
i don't get they call this lady bird and
it's like a lake a river like what's up
what's the colorado river
they got like a billion names
the river with a million names it's just
laid word like lady bird lake
yeah what time did the bats fly out you
missed it you already missed it oh [ __ ]
uh juanita anything you want to say to
paul mart paul black
i don't think so
are you still going to stick with your
boyfriend
am i still what you're you're going to
choose your boyfriend over
yes vanilla sandwich over here we've put
up somebody
we've created such a low connection i
know we
i don't know
we have
uh jimmy walker what do what do you have
to say to juanita anita um thank you for
allowing me in your great state of
mexico
[Laughter]
it's
[Music]
he's got a sense of humor
he needs it watching clownfish all day
yeah
they're not that funny even though
they're they're clowns
a clown human with a correctional
officer they went on a date
and nothing happened but
it was they still did it
thank you guys so much for
sitting there and thank you talking at
each other yes thank you
yeah give it up for jimmy walker and
juanita
that was the whole show
sam what do you think about the whole
night um i was freezing the whole time
i'm gonna say that was the most the
biggest impression um
there was love all around
and love is everywhere
only four people loved it
but we got a lot of viewers on youtube
so i still have a big ego
uh sam you were great did you uh want to
just make fun of uh jimmy walker one
more time
jimmy walker
no i'm too cold to do it i can't make
fun of him it's freezing it's too cold
to be funny freezing it's too cold to be
funny check us out next week and it's
too hot to be sad
oh that sounds awful
welcome to texas jamie walker
hopefully you enjoy our
inability to have abortions here
as in your native florida you should
feel right at home can't kill any babies
he can describe himself
thank you so much for coming out
unless
let's uh ease out of the show with some
smooth jazz
[Music]